hey kids as you know I am one of the
producers on your movie good boys and
unfortunately I'm here with bad news you
guys cannot watch the trailer for your
own movie what it's just too messed up
for kids your age there's drugs there's
violence they're swearing and although
we've decided it's okay for you to do
these things in the movie
you can't watch yourselves do them in
the trailer I feel like right now
especially we're sort of in this
coming-of-age renaissance and it's not
even with high school movies it's with
middle school movies sixth seventh
eighth grade are sort of getting the
kinds of movies that when I was growing
up you know were for high schoolers and
you know why is that you feel like it's
because middle school hasn't been mined
as much in the genre or do you feel like
kids aren't you know the gear younger
and they're sort of they're getting
adult sensibilities at a younger age why
do you think all of a sudden we're
seeing this bloom of middle school
movies I mean I think it's the first
thing and it hasn't really been mined
and also it is such an awkward time and
tell these guys party not knowing you
know kiss - lends itself really well to
comedy and so and kids are growing up
faster so I think for all those reasons
there's been a renaissance you know and
I can stay with you guys for a second
sixth grade you're not in sixth grade so
is it hard to write for sixth grade what
do you have to do are you going into
schools are you sort of sitting down
with sixth graders like just writing for
those sensibilities it's got to be
difficult as you get old we're not I
mean our sensibilities aren't that much
different from a typical sixth grader so
it wasn't that we could tap into that
pretty easily Jacob I want to come to
you and I say this with adoration for
you you've been you know America's
Sweetheart I think you know for a minute
what's it like for you to kind of get
into a bit of a raunchy dangerous movie
I feel like after this movie people are
gonna look are gonna look at Jacob
Tremblay quite the same way again
you took my bag oh my god there's Molly
in there okay who's Molly because she's
not with us Jesus Christ I've been on a
lot of dramas I've never done a comedy
before so I was really excited to do
I thought I'd be a funny experience and
I hope people like it's a really really
fun and funny movie a lot of swearing a
lot of things that could probably
shouldn't be doing around this age but
it's it's really fun it's also
heartwarming to so Brady speaking of the
swearing you know in the trailer a lot
of people watch it your mouth is on fire
you know what's it like you know is that
fun for you but you know what's
interesting about cursing in a movie
there's just saying cursing but there's
the delivery of cursing you know and I
think if you know if you're good you
want to deliver it a certain way in
order to get maximize that laughs and so
do you think about that or you just like
you know do you think about the way
you're delivering the cursing I just say
it what's funniest in my mind and it
comes out good so that's what I've been
just thinking too but yeah we had a rule
like what set on sets days on set so it
was like a good we were fine
transitioning from all the swearing all
the movie to the party with a beer
everyone knows cool what do you have
your pants so when you guys leave the
set and you're going home for the day
you know do you ever find yourself at
dinner just dropping f-bombs and you're
like I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm just like I
had like 15 f-bombs today that I dropped
and I'm just I'm sorry like is that hard
the kind of transition our parents kind
of kept us like made sure I would always
get in trouble let's let's let's say if
you could pass Keith you know the
trailer opens I'm going to talk about
the trailer and trailer opens up you
guys were just kind of playing with sex
toys and it's crazy like how much of
this stuff is explained to you on set or
they just put something in front of you
and say just do something with this and
we're not going to tell you anything
else or we were all just like basically
being like mature about it like you
don't ask questions on set you like ask
your parents later or look it up later
you know it's like yeah look it up later
yeah and like how accurate sort of I you
know to sort of your own lives and
sixth-grade is this how authentic do you
feel you this movie is that's sort of
what you guys were experiencing right
now in your lives it's actually every
middle school kid in every kid that I
know is like my character Brady's
character Jake its character a lot of
middle school kids these days
act like whatever and UI
are you guys big sort of you know fans
of like super bad and and the kind of
films like you know that I wouldn't say
big fans but we we me and Brady when we
saw we liked the movie and we see yeah
we liked the movie you would have loved
it please please PLEASE I mean Keith how
to sleep over on the second to last
night so we watched super bad together
and we had a good time Jean and we did
you show these guys anything did you
want them to see sort of movies in the
genre before before shooting the movie I
think did we have you guys watched stand
by me or you guys seen it already there
are a few there are a few movies that
were kind of like inspirations for us
are kind of touch tones that we talked
about with the guys yeah do you guys
have a personal favorite sort of kind of
movie yet you have a personal favorite
comedy I like the office cuz I was in
the plane I looked next to me and I see
Zach wood who's also in the office I was
like wait a minute wait a minute so I
was on the inside scene I was like mom
switch up a switch with me so we switch
sheets arms next time and then I got to
talk to him anyways it's really cool I
got a picture of them it's that's there
and so as we I would say you have to go
see this movie because it's not just a
like rated hour comedy there's like some
like I guess like inspiration to it too
like basically I think I
the inspiration I'm the one that's
always like pushing people and stuff
like you gotta go get your girl man or
whatever I would say that's not just
like a radar target yeah basically it's
not just a comedy it really touches your
heart when you see it yeah it's not just
like kids cussing and you feel like
middle schoolers should go see it we
probably shouldn't it's pretty it's
pretty it's pretty crazy yeah your
parents don't through I wouldn't run
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
well what do you even kissed well not on
their mouths at least and on that note
good boys is the movie comes out in
August kids and parents will learn some
new things
you